essa pergunta porque 90% das traves
falham
há muita gente tentou responder muita
gente escreveu artigos livros falou
sobre isso mas eu tô aqui pra contar não
que está nos livros mas o que está na
prática de empreender tenta criar uma
empresa no passado quando a gente
imaginava que criar um negócio grande
ficar rico impactar pessoas quem é do
interior pensava só indústrias pois e
chá verde nizzo existe o monte tabor um
dia na cabeça só o abilio diniz por um
homem rico ao belenenses mas como é que
eu podia ser o abilio diniz como é que
eu conseguir chegar lá naquela distância
algo inalcançável inacessível mas hoje
nas condições que nós temos com as
coisas que nós vemos como a tecnologia
evoluiu um de vocês ou vários de vocês
podem criar negócios que vão se tornar
negócios bilionários impactar a vida de
milhares e milhares e milhares de
pessoas
a minha história começou em areado na
cidade de 13 mil habitantes no interior
de minas gerais
lá eu vivi até três anos atrás e foi lá
que eu comecei a minha história
empreendedora profissional então vive
dos meus 38 anos 35 anos laureado ganhar
a décima vez tem cavalo na rua tem
cachorro e tem todo mundo conhece todo
mundo e eu sempre quis fazer muita coisa
eu não me contentava eu olhava próxima
puxa aqui todo mundo é igual a todo
mundo faz as mesmas coisas sabe
exatamente quando é que a pessoa vai
nascer talvez como é que ela vai morrer
que ela vai fazer o que vai acontecer
com a trajetória dela ou vai trabalhar
na prefeitura ia trabalhar aqui na usina
de cana de açúcar que tem lá era quase
que o roteiro já escrito já definido
aí eu sempre tento fazer alguma coisa
diferente mas eu não sabia muito bem o
que fazer
eu achei que podia ser palhaço depois
tenista depois jogador de futebol depois
médico e fiquei viajando e pensando num
monte de coisa mas nada disso parecia
muito provável
ninguém na minha família nada disso nem
minha família tinha saído dali então
como é que eu a algo nascido naquele
lugar podia fazer alguma coisa diferente
o que eu pude encontrar e aí o tempo foi
passando e eu fui seguindo por caminhos
aqui eu não decidi mas que a vida me
levou no meio desses caminhos quando
você não toma as rédeas da sua vida você
não toma decisões você não pensa você
não planeja você não ama não faz um
racional coxa é aqui que eu quero chegar
você não tem um propósito você pode ser
levado para lugares que você a não
esperava e isso pode ser muito ruim
em algum momento da minha vida né eu me
perdi
eu trabalhei por dez anos em uma
universidade é uma cidade próxima da
minha cidade e não antes dez anos eu
levantei de da cama às sete da manhã e
voltei para casa cinco da tarde
sem um propósito eu fiz isso por dez
anos
eu não sei até hoje qual era o meu
objetivo de vida nesses dez anos não
fazia idéia eu fico me pergunta como eu
pude fazer isso como eu pude dos meus 38
anos quase um terço da minha vida
viver sem um propósito e quando eu não
decidiu o que fazer da minha vida quando
eu fui deixando a vida me levar por um
duplo alguns caminhos que me trouxeram
até aqui
como conhecia uma coisa que alguns de
vocês já podem reconhecer que o famoso
fundo do poço
eu sempre falo que fundo do poço ele é
diferente pra muito para algumas pessoas
é o meu fundo do poço é diferente de
vocês que é diferente do outro é
diferente do outro
mas o fundo do poço não é diferentemente
ruim independente de qual seja a
profundidade do seu poço a 2007 voltando
dessa universidade
eu cheguei em casa e eu trabalhava lá a
minha esposa trabalhava lá era um
roteirinho é quase que definida
eu cheguei em casa de uma pessoa que
cuidava do meu filho tinha seis meses
ela julho lá faz bastante frio
estava chovendo eu cheguei em casa às
cinco e meia da tarde a pessoa que
cuidava do meu filho pra gente poder
trabalhar
estava esperando rua e eu entendi porque
ela estava na rua que eu viria esquina
ela roubou meu filho garoando frio quase
esclarecendo já estava escuro e eu
cheguei porque estão de fora tá frio
neve para dentro de seis meses só e ela
me disse que não dava para levar ele pra
dentro porque energia elétrica na casa
cortada eu não tinha dinheiro não tinha
dinheiro para pagar energia elétrica da
minha casa
naquele momento naquele dia naquele
momento lembro como se fosse hoje fico
até arrepiado
aquele dia eu conheci o meu fundo do
poço
tudo o que eu tinha feito nos últimos
dez anos tinha me levado para aquele
lugar para aquele exato momento uma vida
profissional uma vida pessoa sem
propósito eu não conseguia entender qual
era o sentido que eu poderia dar para a
minha vida e aqueles sonhos todos que eu
tinha lá atrás de ser além de médico
jogador de futebol piloto de avião
qualquer coisa que eu pudesse imaginar
tinha sido enterrado no momento em que
eu deixei a vida me levar
sem conseguir minimamente tomar decisões
ou pensar racionalmente que eu queria
fazer nesse dia ele também marcou porque
ele foi o dia que eu decidir mudar
completamente essa história
nesse dia eu decidi que o rei e eu me
correr conectaria com aquela criança que
estava lá atrás que era sonhadora nesse
depois desse dia nas dez dias depois
eu pedi demissão a da universidade e eu
fui fazer várias outras coisas
só que quando você está numa situação
ruim e tenta mudar a tendência é ficar
muito pior se fica muito pior e ficou
muito pior
depois o primeiro foi energia elétrica
pois perdi meu carro depois vocês não
têm idéia do que aconteceu nos sete anos
seguintes foram sete anos em que tudo o
que eu tentei fazer deu errado
tudo que eu tenho de fazer errado eu
tentei empreender diversas formas
eu tentei perder fábrica de marmita a
fábrica de vassoura porque estampa de
camiseta
não quero imaginar que eu tentei fazer e
tudo dava errado não havia uma coisa que
funcionasse
e aí nesse quando chegou num momento
marcado porque está tudo dando errado
porque eu não consigo fazer a minha
estratégia minha vida os meus sonhos
acontecer
como o que tá te puxa tantas coisas eu
tô tá acontecendo falhando errando
errando errando e aí eu percebi eu tô
errado mas eu não estou aprendendo com
os meus erros
eu estou errando fazendo as mesmas
coisas repetindo os mesmos erros e
aquilo não time trazendo um aprendizado
não estou sendo capaz de aprender com as
minhas próprias falhas
nessa época houve essa frase do mandela
que diz o seguinte é estão lendo e eu
quero desmerecer
ela fala ah eu nunca perco ou eu aprendo
eu ganho
e aí quando eu conheci essa frase quando
eu li eu fico mentalmente eu fico
imaginando as situações que são aquelas
que eu vou tentar foi imaginado e aí eu
vou tentando criar um racional a cabeça
para superar esses desafios
e aí eu falei poxa essa frase faz
sentido porque esse é o meu objetivo
está ali no fundo daquela sala e eu
tenho sem erros pra cometer até chegar
no meu objetivo
se eu cometi um fóton 99 basta ser capaz
de me reinventar e capaz de ser
resiliente o suficiente para cometer o
segundo tiro na frente o terceiro é da
frente e aprender com o próximo com o
próximo com o próximo até atingir meu
objetivo
e foi assim que nessa época eu conseguir
assimilar essa essa coisa na minha
cabeça que eu precisava fazer diferente
e aprender com os meus erros e algumas
dessas palavras começaram a pipocar na
minha cabeça
você precisa transformar se precisa se
reinventar se reconectar você precisa
mudar
eu falava mas como eu faço isso aonde
que eu busco ajuda para isso acontecer
como é que eu posso mudar esse jogo e aí
eu vi que nesse momento cada uma dessas
palavras
tinha que ter uma coisinha no final que
era um se transforme se mude se
reinvente e algo que vem de dentro pra
fora não é o que vem de fora para dentro
a gente precisa conhecer as nossas
forças interiores e não só ser medidos
pelo que a gente vê por que as pessoas
nos vêem por fora nessa formação pelas
habilidades mas a força que vem de
dentro
e foi nessa época em 2015
que eu te fundei a estar se a start seu
nome estar disse ele vem da palavra
estar mesmo pra começar
mas esse se no final fez toda a
diferença porque ele mostrou ele
conectou m conseguiu traduzir tudo
aquilo que eu enxergava e precisava ver
num start se isso aquilo e isso virou um
propósito na minha vida porque esse
start se provocou em mim um novo começo
foi um ponto de recomeço na minha vida e
não porque é por causa disso o nosso
propósito hoje é provocar novos começos
por cada pessoa que passa pela start
cada pessoa que passa pelos nossos
eventos cada pessoa que se relaciona com
nosco de alguma maneira e são milhões de
pessoas todos os anos nosso objetivo é
que ela tenha pequenos novos começos
meu objetivo aqui hoje é fazer com que
cada um volte pra casa e que uma dessas
palavrinhas que eu disser seja o gatilho
para um novo começo uma pequena mudança
porque a gente sabe que por ouvir
experiências ouvir relatos se reconectar
faz com que a gente talvez tenha uma
atitude diferente e consiga encontrar um
novo caminho e quando eu queria estar aí
eu pensei poxa é bom agora encontrei uma
coisa que faz sentido tomando as rédeas
da minha vida isso vai funcionar
meu caminho até o sucesso vai ser fácil
e não foi o que pareceu muitos desafios
aconteceram e eu aprendi nesse caminho o
motivo pelo qual essas trata-se da
paixão porque eu cometi todas essas
falhas na construção do start até agora
primeiro a você tem que se apaixonar
novembro sendo as tardes falham porque
ela se apaixonou pelo produto e não pelo
problema
quando você transforma o seu produto a
sua empresa seu negócio no seu filho é
se não tiver de errado em línguas
faladas linha ouvindo que o filho é feio
fica chato filho é isso que o filho
aquilo mas é preciso ouvir que o produto
é ruim que ele não está legal que não
resolve o problema que ele atende então
primeiro erro primeiro ponto que estas
falham e se apaixonar pelo seu produto
elas vão se apaixonar pelo seu pro
o lema segundo elas não têm foco
quando a gente começou a estar se eu
queria fazer milhares de coisas e fazer
milhares de coisas ao mesmo tempo não
funciona que fazer uma coisa só bem
feita já é difícil imagina fazer duas
três quatro cinco passam pela star disse
nós temos uma plataforma com 13 mil
startups e várias pessoas em eventos vêm
falar com investidores e falou poxa eu
tenho uma startup diz anã mas eu invisto
em saúde ou visto só em água não o museu
também tem uma ideia para o agro fazer
uma coisa só é difícil fazer duas é
quase impossível 3 então nem se fala que
a empreender desde que se tenha forte e
faça uma coisa de cada vez e bem feito o
terceiro
as pessoas têm medo de correr riscos não
arrisca uma coisa muito diferente muito
difícil tomar risco quando você se lança
para algo que você não conhece a você
entra num quase que num desafio mental
coxa o caminho que todo mundo vai por
aqui por que que eu vou pôr aqui só que
se você analisar a história da startup
recentes todas as que ousaram pegar o
caminho diferente
foram as que tiveram sucesso imagine uma
rodovia todos os carros vão na mesma
direção o carro que pega o atalho corre
mais risco mas ele tenha a chance chega
primeiro e quem chega primeiro no
mercado de startups nesse mundo de novo
de inovação e tecnologia
bebe água limpa o baby a 99
todos eles não seguiram pelo caminho
tradicional ousaram fazer diferente
conquistaram resultados expressivos 4
demorou muito para lançar o seu produto
quando a startup demoram para lançar
elas vão falhar porque elas não estão
ouvindo o cliente elas não estão
recebendo os feedbacks
então quanto mais rápido se lançar mesmo
que seja ruim feio coloca lá porque vão
te dizer coisas que talvez não sabe eu
não tinha percebido não existe melhor
validação para o lançamento de um
produto de uma startup do que o mercado
por mais que você tenha todas as
hipóteses vale dadas a última
o mais importante é alguém vai pagar por
isso alguém vai comprar o produto
você só vai descobrir isso quando for
pelo mercado se for tarde demais
alguém pode ter feito a conquistado e
apreendido 1º e aí perdeu a hora perdeu
o jogo tem baixo diversidade
esse é um ponto que eu fico pensando as
pessoas ficam falando na minha empresa é
muito diversa eu tenho há pessoas de
raças diferentes religiões diferentes
orientação sexual diferente mas tem
pessoas de diversidade de pensamento
uma vez alguém vem falou vou montar uma
startup vou eu meu amigo eu sou melhor
aluno de ciência da computação da usp
vôo junto com o segundo melhor aluno eo
terceiro melhor aluno montar uma
estratégia beleza não ser um ótimo
emprego de tecnologia ninguém sabe falar
né é só conversar então habilidades
diferentes e complementares
isso é o que faz a diversidade
verdadeira acontecer
a 6º sócios em conflito
essa é qualquer manual reportagens
louback conflito entre os sócios é uma
das principais causas de mortalidade de
startup de sócio é ruim não ter sócio
fundamental nas tardes em 70 pessoas não
somos 29 sócios e eu queria que todos os
70 funcionários fossem sócios porque
nenhum funcionário se dedica tanto
quanto um sócio com um dono
então quanto mais pessoas relevantes
você trouxer o negócio e quanto mais
essas pessoas que fizerem mais forte
mais valioso a empresa ser mais robusta
elas merecem ser sócias elas merecem ser
donas do pedaço disso não tem propósito
quando você faz uma coisa sem propósito
você perde uma coisa extremamente
relevante que a autenticidade itaú
bradesco grandes marcas de grandes
bancos no brasil todos têm dinheiro
suficiente para fazer o quê no bem que
fez porque demoraram para fazer e agora
não conseguem recuperar o espaço pequeno
bem que desde o dia 04 com o cliente no
centro a pessoa é
coisa mais importante do mundo bem que
essa foi a grande inovação dele porque
que hoje quando esses grandes bancos
tentam colocar pessoas no centro não
funciona como funciona um plano bem que
falta de autenticidade
eles podiam ter feito antes e não
fizeram só fizeram agora porque foram
incomodados com autenticidade e está
conectada ao propósito não comem a
comida do cachorro as teclas que falham
elas não comem a comida mas não vão
portar um bingo no balcão não querem
falar com o cliente na start a gente faz
eventos o ano todo passam 40 mil pessoas
pelos nossos eventos e eu sempre chegava
no evento tinha uma fila enorme de
pessoas no credenciamento eu chegar
passava bonitinho pelo por dentro do
balcão pegava o meu crachá entrava em 30
segundos
no dia que eu fiquei na fila por uma
hora tendo a mesma experiência que os
meus clientes tinham a gente mudou
a gente mudou ea gente consegue fazer o
credenciamento de 40 mil pessoas
divididas em 20 e ventos em dois minutos
mas eu tive que comer comida do cachorro
pra conseguir enxergar esse desafio esse
problema a 9 não aceitam falhas
esse é um é uma coisa muito muita gente
fala ah você tem que incentivar as
pessoas ao erro
errar é muito bom quando o erro vem
acompanhado de um aprendizado e hannah
verrà puramente ray muito ruim
ninguém gosta de errar e nós fazer uma
coisa que não funciona
mas se o erro vem acompanhado de um
aprendizado aí é um ponto importante ele
é algo importante então não incentive as
pessoas a errarem a seguir as pessoas a
tomarem risco e se errarem aprenderem
com erro
é isso que faz evoluir mas as etapas
elas têm medo do erro tem medo da falha
e têm medo de tomar risco como disse
atrás e aí quando você tem esses medos a
inovação acontece e por último as etapas
não são capazes de se reinventar quando
a coisa não funciona a reinventar
se reconectar reaprender ter o seu start
se interior é o que faz de você que faz
a diferença entre steve jobbs e qualquer
um de nós aqui ninguém
mark zuckerberg steve jobs bill gates
nenhum dessas pessoas que tiveram
sucesso absurdo fizeram coisas
gigantescas que transformaram a
humanidade são melhores que nós
eu tenho a oportunidade destacou
bernardinho que é o triângulo de vôlei
pelo menos uma vez por mês nessa luta
toda vez que eu toco bernardinho ele me
falou o seguinte talento todo mundo tem
mas quem vence é quem trabalha mais é
quem acredita mais é quem é resiliente é
quem tenta
talvez steve jobs tenha tentado muito
mais que qualquer outra pessoa por isso
que ele fez o que ele fez
hoje nós temos oportunidade de fazer
coisas extremamente relevantes e nós só
conseguimos fazer isso na start quando a
gente se reinventou
quando eu me reinventei quando a empresa
se reinventar em quatro anos diversas
vezes e hoje com muito orgulho a nós
somos uma empresa que impacta milhares
de pessoas milhões de pessoas online
milhares de pessoas em eventos em cursos
temos uma sede no brasil estados unidos
na china
só uma empresa de fachada algumas
centenas de milhões
mas tudo isso aconteceu porque nós
aprendemos com os nossos erros porque
nós nos reconectar anos como coco
conosco mesmo e conseguimos evoluir
muito molhado
[Aplausos]